we can't talk back to school without
talking before and after school programs
the Boys and Girls Club of Southern
Nevada provides a safe affordable and
accessible solution for parents with
schedules that might not align with
their kids so let's welcome Andy Bishop
president and CEO of the Boys and Girls
Club of Southern Nevada thank you for
all you do welcome I appreciate you
having us such an important role you
have um let's talk about just the demand
you're seeing so far only just a few
days in yeah you know for before and
after school programs and we're rolling
right out of summer so we're open all
summer and and getting back to the
school year but uh really shifts a
little bit to the those kids draw right
from the school so we either do
walkovers or van pickups to to fill up
our clubs that's awesome and and let's
break it down but between those phrases
I mentioned earlier safe affordable and
accessible let's start with safety how
do you make this safe both physical and
emotional right
um those are both really key components
so we want to create a safe environment
for kids where they feel part of the
group because once that happens then all
learning starts absolutely I think they
learn they're more successful when they
feel safe right yep and any let's talk
about all
can they afford these programs they can
it's it's a 35 annual fee and and then
there is a 40 fee but we also have a
need-based
scholarships and funding through the
child care assistance grants so we can
if you contact the clubs that we can
walk you through that application
process absolutely you guys are there
for all of us let's talk about the
programs right you know what break those
down for us what are you actually giving
to the kids yeah really academic success
is kind of the key we we want to work
with kids we want to have fun right
because they've been in school all day
so we want to start with fun burn some
energy but then we're going to do some
homework help with them and go and and
really when it when we start breaking
down we want to do some art uh also so
that they get that creative uh flow too
but again it's around that healthy
lifestyle and academic success that all
of our programs focus and to add you
know it's all about leadership and
character building as well right what
are the the other benefits the kids are
getting that's that is everything that
is the essence of boys and girls club
you're learning leadership skills but
you're also learning to follow too so
that athletic kid gets to lead out on
the basketball court the artistic child
gets to lead in the art room the
academic minded kids can actually peer
lead when they're doing homework help
and then technology also well how can
confirmation
bgcsnv.org so boys and girls club
Southern Nevada dot org all right well
thank you so much Andy again for all you
guys do for the community you're so
important Mercedes I'll send it to you